gérard davet et fabrice lhomme sont avec
nous merci d'être avec gérard mercier
visage est ouvert une enquête
spotlight en seine saint denis alors
déjà gérard davet auteur du livre
inch'allah bien sûr et journaliste pour
le journal le monde on vous connaît
fabrice lhomme pareil vous c'est un duo
voilà qui avait déjà écrit un livre qui
avait beaucoup fait parler sur sur notre
ancien président françois hollande
vous êtes de retour donc avec ce livre
écrit en collaboration avec cinq de vos
élèves
une enquête rondement mené pendant neuf
mois vous avez recueilli 21 témoignage
pour construire cette enquête
alors pourquoi ce nom de livres
inch'allah parce qu'on va voir justement
une vidéo de vous vous avez beaucoup
brainstorm et gérard peut-être on
fabrique quand vous voulez quand vous
voulez en fait pourquoi d'abord le
principe c'est que on est on est on a
été conforme des jeunes à lenquête
depuis des années là en l'occurrence on
avait envie de d d une cellule d'enquêté
de jeunes du journaliste a enquêté sur
ce sujet qu'on estimait intéressant pour
cour estime intéressant parce que
françois hollande justement nous en
avait parlé lors de nos entretiens nous
avait dit clairement l'islam a un
problème il ya un problème avec l'islam
en france or ça venant d'un président de
gauche c'était quand même pas très
courant donc on s'est dit on va vérifier
sur le terrain donc ces jeunes
enquêteurs sont allés sur le terrain ils
n'ont pas rencontré vingt-et-une
personnes et plus de 200 personnes pour
justement ramener ce livre que nous
avons aidé à mettre en forme et le fond
c'est vraiment eu leurs interviews c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment et c'est ce
qu'on dit alors alors on va voir une
vidéo de vous vous êtes en train de
brainstorming vous n'êtes pas tous
forcément d'accord sur le nom du livre
regarder alors en fait on s'est dit que
les meilleurs qui marchait c'était
toujours compte y avait une expression
un peu usuelle des tournées et si dieu
le veut
ok le fait de traduire l'expression en
français ça montre que en fait la
religion musulmane les religions
française les religions qui s'est ancrée
dans le voile en france qui est venue
quelque chose on peut pas faire sans
l'islam aujourd'hui en france en fait
donc le fait de la traduire c'est très
bien inch allah ça aurait été moins
intéressant tu vois mais outre si dieu
le veut et inch'allah je me ferais du
tchad à voir voilà alors vous avez donc
choisi inch allah vous personnellement
et ça a été retenu après alors déjà ckoi
l'islamisation
c'est tout simplement l'application de
normes religieuses dans le musulmane
l'occurrence dans le champ de la vie
sociale française que ce soit dans la
santé que ce soit dans l'éducation que
ce soit dans la police nationale et
ailleurs donc c'est d'irruption de
normes religieuses dans la vie de tous
les jours alors vous vous posez la
question l'islamisation de la
seine-saint-denis un fait ou une fake
news vous avez donc envoyer vos lavaud
vos élèves voilà allait faire tout cette
enquête il venait vous rapporter voilà
comment ça se passait au niveau du trail
parce qu'on on a pas mal de vidéos ils
venaient pour apporter à chaque fois les
témoignages qu'ils avaient reçus à
fabrice oui mais plus que ça c'est à
dire que d'abord inouïe nous relatait
les le contenu des interviews qui
recueillait mais surtout en permanence
on se posait la question de savoir où on
allait est-ce qu'ils étaient en train de
trouver est-ce que c'est ce que ça
disait du territoire faut bien savoir
que cette enquête illustre j'allais dire
la façon dont un journaliste enquête
doit procéder
et si un peu une méthode j'allais dire
un peu schizophrène c'est pas facile
c'est à dire que on dit toujours pour
trouver faut savoir ce qu'on cherche
donc on part avec pas un présupposé mais
une intuition 1 un but à poursuivre mais
il ne faut pas exclure de faire demi
tour
or la plume idées avancées eux-mêmes
qu'ils sont qui sont tous cinq étudiants
aujourd'hui journalistes tous nos
opinions politiques différentes
d'origine différente etc
au fur et à mesure ils s'accordaient
tous sur le même point à savoir que oui
leslie mann islamisation dont certains
d'entre eux pouvaient douter au départ
est bien présente en seine-saint-denis
sans d'ailleurs on en parlera peut-être
sans qu'on dise forcément que ce soit un
drame
nous on n'est pas là pour dire si c'est
bien si c'est pas bien on va les
documenter le fait que ça c'est quelque
chose qui me existe et moral alors on
voit d'ailleurs vos journalistes sur le
terrain
regardez sec dans mon film et
j'en ai pas vu des commerces
vestimentaire halal il y en a pourtant
de quoi peut-être les une panne chez
nous c'est là où sochaux
vous avez des demandes en religieuse par
exemple vestimentaire il y en a aucune
vous voyez plus de port de signes
religieux que les depuis des années on
va parler d'une salle de prière ici à la
fac de saint denis notamment pour le
vendredi
est ce que tu en as entendu parler ou
pas du tout non pas du tout si vraiment
il ya un lieu ici pour faire la prière
et cemaf alors on va revenir donc sur le
livre et les passages forts du livre
déjà vous parlez des commerces un
passage voilà sur la restauration de
celui que vous appelez le guide est
assez fort il parle donc de la
restauration et pour lui toute la
nourriture à saint denis est
exclusivement halal sur la devanture de
tous les kebabs fast food et autres
pizzerias on peut lire l'inscription
halal licite en arabe même chose sur les
vitrines des boucheries du quartier où
figure le tampon bleus avs à votre
service
l'un des organes pionnier dans la
certification halal en france alors on a
posé la question aux téléspectateurs
donc la question nous poser dans libre
on l'a posée également à nos
intervenants l'islamisation de la seine
saint denis un fait ou ne fait que nous
on va parler des passages les plus forts
du livre vous pour vous karim zéribi
c'est un c'est un fait moi ce que je
pense c'est que en fait c'est un peu du
réchauffé ce livre ce que la plupart de
ce que je qualifie comme étant des faits
sont des choses connues qui ont déjà été
relaté en 2015 2016 pour les citer 1
donc on parle d'un dépôt ratp
c'est dans l'obs après les attentats du
13 novembre 2015
on parle du rapport de jean pierre aubin
c'est dans l'express en 2015 on parle de
roissy qui poserait un problème à
chasser dans marianne 2016 de en fait
j'ai l'impression que c'est une
compilation de juxtaposition d'éléments
qu'on avait déjà notre connaissance et
qui sont posées pelle des faits nouveaux
or il n'y a pas de nouveauté ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point je
considère ça a été dit par un des
auteurs que la démarche n'est pas
idéologique
ils se sont défendus sur tous les
plateaux dix ans nous n'avons pas eu des
marchés de rue je veux bien les croire
je suis
assez convaincus qu'ils ont une démarche
commerciale avec ce lien alors
simplement par le titre est d'ailleurs
une réunion de rédaction un moment donné
où il évoque le titre où l'un des deux
se plus lequel dit inch allah c'est un
titre racoleur titre racoleur ça veut
dire mon année ça va vendre donc ça pour
moi c'est une démarche plus commercial
que journalistique
3 c'est pas un délit de vente mais on
voit la recherche derrière troisième et
dernier point j'ai envie de dire que est
ce que ces faits qui peuvent être des
anecdotes de comportements qu'on trouve
inacceptable parfois inquiétants sont à
globaliser sur un département
c'est la question que je me pose parce
qu'à un moment donné ils disent la seine
saint denis
c'est un million six cent mille
habitants et ses 700 à 800 mille
musulmans
ah bon vous êtes allés chercher les
chiffres où il ya un expert dont j'ai le
nom s'appelle wilfrid cerisier qui
travaille sur la seine saint denis qui
était un chercheur du 10 mai jamais de
la vie
on peut pas sortir des chiffres pareils
ça n'existe pas on peut pas faire de
statistiques ethniques ou religieux dans
le pays le rcsa tout ça nous paraît tout
ce que je viens d'évoquer encore une
fois je dis que c'est fait donc je ne
nie pas qu'ils aient des comportements
qui peuvent prouver pose des questions
attention mais jeudi que la manière dont
s'est présenté la manière dont on a fait
la promotion peu tendre à confusion il
ya 6 millions de musulmans en france
moi je veux rappeler haut et fort dans
cette émission que ils trouvent leur
place dans la société française et leurs
pratiques et leur foi
elle est exercée en compatibilité totale
avec la république et la laïcité
donc il ne faudra pas faire lever donner
l'impression que de comportements que je
qualifierais peut-être anecdotique qu'il
faut combattre qu'il faut évoquer qu'il
ne faut pas cacher ce qu'il n'y a pas de
tabou et que ça ne peuvent pas être pris
à l'échelle d'un département world
international un comble alors on va
laisser fabrice et fabrice lhomme et
gérard davet répondre après on aura eric
naulleau c'est très court sur les
différents points évoqués
j'en prends au hasard sur le titre 10 et
c'est racoleur
je dis c'est qu'il était plus racoleur
oui et je vis en fait plus vendeur parce
que j'assume que le premier titre qui
était si dieu le veut qu'ils ne on sait
pas à quoi ça fait allusion mais par
ailleurs moi j'ai aucun problème avec ce
titre qui à mon avis est neutre je pense
qu'on devrait aller mais plus débattent
du sous titre qui pourrait faire débat
le titre
c'est une phrase banale mais on l'a mise
parce que chaque interlocuteur de ou
quasiment chaque interlocuteur de nos
journalistes disaient ça à la fin de la
plaisance qui attire le téléspectateur
l'islam à visage découvert ensuite je
prédis que vous disiez même s'ils sont
pas pratiques à celle là c'est devenu
presque une exception si elle n'est pas
prête vite là alors excusez moi juste à
pouvoir des révélations ne reconnaît
personne je ne connais aucun auteur de
livres hauteur de disques
je ne connais même aucun député qui
fasse campagne qu'ils fassent en se
disant j'ai essayé de me faire le moins
de bruit possible
j'ai essayé de pas être élue je vais
essayer de pas bon bon livre ou des pas
vendre notamment de monique bah si c'est
ça et non un livre c'est normal tu as du
tout le même si un journal c'est fait
pour être vendus ben non ça me donne un
visage découvert je vous ai dit ça dans
mon argumentaire que comme y avait rien
de nouveau il n'y a pas de visage de la
soirée les artistes et en rosé margut
vous avez tort tandis que de nouveaux
iaconelli goûter offert après si je vous
ai donné les référentiels et la
direction et la direction de la police
judiciaire
j'ai fait un très bon d'y aller après la
famille de barbie il est question d
accord au moins sur deux points avec
l'analyse de karim d'abord il dit on
connaît tous sa mais l'intérêt du livre
de davié l'homme c'est que tous les
faits sont rassemblés dans un seul livre
et ça prouve que à partir d'un certain
degré de concentration ethnique
le communautarisme se met en marche de
toutes les manières possibles et fini
par saturer un territoire ensuite karim
dit une autre chose qui est vraie en
soit il dit mais la plupart des
musulmans ce qui est vrai vive
tranquillité avec la république et la
laïcité des explosifs dans la préface
oui mais ce que montrent davet et
l'homme sait que les premières victimes
de cet islamiste que ce sont les
musulmans qui les musulmans éclairés les
musulmans des lumières qui se retrouve
en minorité mais sur mon quartier
dans mon quartier curial ramadan il ya
des femmes qui est musulman qui font la
chasse à d'autres femmes musulmanes qui
ne pratiquent pas le ramadan et ont fait
fermer des commerces tenus par des
musulmans qui vendent du port donc ce
sont les musulmans modérés j'aime pas
cette expression les musulmans ouvert
qui sont les premières victimes et eux
ils quitteront les rangs de la
république et la laïcité pour verser
dans l'islamisme pour être tranquille
simplement sur ce territoire
les ira jusqu'à une question à monsieur
zéribi est-ce que vous avez bien vu
entendu parler une préfète déléguée à
l'égalité des chances qui vous parle
très longuement et de manière ouverte en
assumant ses propos sur ce qu'elle
constate en termes d'islamisation d'un
département
j'ai terminé j'ai pas terminée est-ce
que vous allez rencontrer un journaliste
qu'elle est rentrée dans un dépôt de la
ratp
je continue à dire beaucoup est ce que
vous les journalistes qui sont rentrés
dans les écoles salafiste et qui vous
raconte qu'il ya des dessins d'enfants
il n'y a pas de visage la musique et
athènes est-ce que vous en connaissez si
vous dites oui alors franchement je vais
ses yeux fermés ce que je voulais dire
c'est la thématique en a déjà été nommé
monsieur la même manière par et bien
vous la mettre en avant les faits 1 sur
ce qui m'a dit à définir mais je n'avais
jamais alors merci je ne voulais pas les
étudiants gérard davet et fabrice lhomme
j'aimerais qu'on vienne un peu sur le
livre lisez vous dites également vous
parler des bombes une dizaine d'années
les industries de pâtisserie de beaumont
de cosmétiques et même les agences de
voyages se sont mises aux filons pureté
consommer halal est devenu une évidence
à saint denis de fait quasiment une
obligation sur la littérature vous dit
désormais le centre de saint denis
compte trois librairies religieuses à la
librairie la mecque situé face à
l'église saint-denis delestrez au bout
de la république au bout de la rue de la
république à rayons entiers s'adresse
aux femmes musulmanes
on y trouve des ouvrages au titre
éloquent femme au foyer re découvre ton
chez toi polygamie ou ton mari à toi
seul ou encore droits et devoirs de la
femme en islam
on est tombé aussi sur des passages très
limite donc dans les livres voilà que
vous avez vous avait relaté ta maison
est il écrit c'est au royaume citons et
pour rentrer du travail et trouve
l'intérieur de la maison mal ronge et
est sale
il partira ailleurs jusqu'à ce que tout
redevienne propre et bien rangé
pareil pour la mode au numéro 23 de la
rue l'eshop les branches et propose des
voiles de toutes sortes turban bandeau
et voilà la boutique dubaï secteur a les
mêmes en taille enfant
il n'est pas rare de croiser le mercredi
les petites silhouettes intrigante des
fillettes voilées se rendant à des cours
d'arabe alors vous vous dites que c'est
fake on vous pose la question qui est
posée dans le livre de gérard davet et
fabrice lhomme donc l'islamisation de la
seine saint denis un fait ou une fac
news vous dit une fake
oui mais je dis que j'aurais pu très
bien m'être fait c'est pourquoi je dis
ça mais pourquoi tu dis ça parce que moi
je connais pas moi que je vais dans le
93 j'ai vu jouer au stade de france
oui je l ai toujours
je connais pas ces ados que je vais pas
dire vous allez d'écouter ses moyens et
ça c'est pas possible c'est pas vrai par
contre j'ai l'accord et karim c'est que
ça on l'entend dire depuis vingt ans
mais moi j'étais au gouvernement de
nicolas sarkozy françois fillon on
l'entendait dire déjà ça fait chic et
muscat déchets en fin de vie et ricard
et de son agir un petit peu et il va
rapporte que des karim sur cyril à
certains l'envié tout à l'heure les
barbecues fait par les policiers alors
le l'avenir on va retenir souris n'est
pourtant pas seulement ce que je
voudrais c'est parce que ce passage
tournant pas donc on va on va en parler
d'accord avec l'été laisse moi je suis
comme ça vous ou par les policiers ce
que pouvait raconter ce passage nos
téléspectateurs parce que oui voilà il
volera côté bien que moi je peux vous le
racontez moi déjà la polémique du
barbecue c'est très simple très simple
c'est un barbecue qui se déroule au sein
de la police judiciaire dans un petit
village s'appelle toujours au nord du
département et chacun chaque année la
bmpj fait un petit pot comme ça et dans
ce pot il est arrivé qu'il y ait des
gens qui est se plaignent parce que
l'avion n'était pas halal c'est remonter
jusqu'aux hautes autorités de la pj et
ça a créé effectivement débat au sein de
la pj après la pj a fait les communiqués
les syndicats ont fait des comics en
disant ça n'est jamais arrivé effet pas
le syndicat et la direction
la direction c'est ça la justice ou
l'annoncé se passe ça se passe rien
alors je voulais aller chez swiss ce
passage a fait énormément parler ça on
en avait parlé dans les jt mais on est
quand vous savez on te dis qu'on peut
l'affiché le film déjà le passage parce
que c'est les syndicats allaient partout
regardez moi ces mêmes dans les jt tout
le monde en a parlé on va fils et qu'on
va nager c'est simple ce sont les singes
et les jt siouplaît le jt est que ce
soit le syndicat s'est passé ceci à dire
qu'il ya des récriminations qui ont été
adressées par les gens de deux d'origine
eu de relation de religion musulmane qui
ont été adressées à la direction de la
pj nizon on veut du halal il ya trop de
femmes qui manipulent les barbecues et
voilà et ça s'arrête là et c'est
pourtant lamirand pourquoi l'année au
début de ce livre c'est parce que c'est
une anecdote que je trouve révélatrice
mais qui ne reste qu'une anecdote est
effectivement comme le dit monsieur
duval
on n'a pas plu à pas parce que ils
voient pas l'intérêt d'en parler a
précédé qu'une anecdote alors c'est ce
passage n'a pas du tout plu il ya
abdoulaye kanté un fonctionnaire de
police eu des mots qui démontre
complètement qui écrivent à nice c'est
vrai il faut le dire oui alors
il s'en tire même des rivaux plus ces
compteurs reconnu crs quand il passe
d'un fait qui s'est déroulée très
récemment au l'an passé il a été annulée
pour cause de pluie en 2016 et 2017
il tombait en plein mois de ramadhan les
collègues musulmans n'étaient pas là
alors c'est quand alors vous parlez de
ce passage bernard laporte voulait avec
c'est ce que je dis je le dis parce que
vous avez inquiétez donc ambitieux comme
à vous comment vous croire mais comme je
vous dis ça fait 20 ans qu'on nous dise
ah vous avez été encore plus loin avec
des élèves etc
et je vois trop fragile et il est
magnifique mais moi j'ai envie de garder
espoir pour ça que j'ai mitage et
j'espère que c'est j'espère que c'est
pas vrai c'est mieux c'est qu'on n'a pas
dépassé la limite non mais je pense que
l'un n'empêche pas l'autre
oui je pense moi que ça j'espère qu'on
leur ait été trop loin malheureusement
pour inverser la marche arrière pour les
fichiers pour répondre sur un trafic
quasi-nul étouffé bien j'espère que
c'est que vous avez raison parce que si
nous avait manqué d'assurer gobain on
est malade il faut déchirer d'accord
avec vous mais demandez à voir comment
on pourrait avoir l'idée m'est
complètement dingue se dire tiens on va
inventer cette anecdote quelle bonne
idée
oui honnêtement on est des malades
mentaux qui mène par ailleurs une teinte
et ailleurs balzac il ne sait pas qui
manque à ce qu'il ne sait pas mais le
guerrier dis halte au poids mais peu
importe communiqué ce qui est drôle et
non laissez moi j'ai pas dans la villa
mais laissez-moi fabriquer ces mois
terminée l'arbre la signature wiiware et
la direction régionale direction reste
on peut on imaginer en cinq minutes
qu'une direction
bah non c'est pas le gérer la direction
met sommes pas sûrs du syndicat qu'elle
le valide aurait passé rien le problème
c'est que vous êtes passionné par cette
année va briser sur cette histoire là
notamment libération qui nous a appelé
pour dire est ce que c'est vraiment
risquer des policiers qui démonte et
finalement le type de libération a fait
son papier sur le site internet parce
que sans doute qu'il avait pas trouvé ce
qu'il aurait voulu trouver il n'a pas
fait dans le dans le papier parce
qu'évidemment ça n'allait pas et ce
qu'il voulait expliquer c'est à dire que
là ils ont tout inventé
ah bah oui effectivement on a trouvé
trace au moins d'un an au moins d'un
incident en 2014 ou des policiers
effectivement on redemande et de la
viande halal donc je voulais le débat
chloé ce n'est même pas notre anecdote
un an et dit non mais si le débat et aux
messieurs je voudrais pas qu'on
journalistes qui balaye d'un revers de
main un communiqué qui dit les choses
mais s'excuse moi c'est pas facile
je suis atterré en fait aussi sa maman
ce qu'on vous dit mais si vous aimez moi
je fais coach l eau à la direction
jeunesse de la plage héritière n'arrive
pas dans la police j'ai plus confiance
avoue a eu qu à vous et à la direction
je voudrais rendre hommage à cet ouvrage
au moins sur un point c'est qu'il évite
les deux travers qui sont communs à ce
genre de démarche soit le déni soit le
délire il n'y a pas de déni parce que ça
me semble difficile de nier quand même
que l'islamisme essaye de mettre la main
sur la seine seine saint denis c'est
normal à partir d'un certain seuil de
concentration et ça évite le délire
parce que par exemple davet et l'homme
n'a pas été signalée font justice d'une
légende urbaine de ce bar qui serait
réservée aux femmes a souvent vous savez
ça faisait ça agite l opinion arbitre
avait déjà été démontré par monalisa les
gens comme quoi il y avait un bar en
plein second rang qui était exactement
interdit aux femmes ils ont envoyé des
gens et d'ailleurs ils ont fait un
travail tout parce qu'on est la réalité
que qui est déterrée n'est pas forcément
cette étude fait nous allons au
contraire
en tout cas cela est démonté c'est pas
eux qui l'ont démonté et je trouve que
c'est un an a été fait déjà sur noblesse
viol aurait brandi ces oeuvres qui
savait mais bon et c'est en tant que
consommateur à charge c'est un livre
équilibré ni emballage hamadi qui est à
charge justement cet examen médical et
vocaux saviez donc l'évolution dans les
rituels des habitants de la
seine-saint-denis vous démontez
également donc quelques idées reçues
comme cette histoire de grosses
polémiques du café de sevran
prétendument interdit aux femmes
s'étaient passées même dans le jt de
france 2 souvenez-vous ça avait fait
beaucoup parler et en fait c'était une
légende regarde la diarrhée magna et
aziza sayah se battre pour la liberté
des femmes dans ces quartiers pour nous
montrer la réaction des hommes
elle filme dans un bar en caméra cachée
quelqu'un dans ce bar que des sommes pas
très accueillant le mieux c'est
d'attendre pourquoi il va se faire
discrète petite dans un coin dans ce
café ya pas de mixité est ce que c'est
normal
même à sevran c'est la france c'est en
86 à l'heure locale
c'est des mentalités différentes et
comme on est allé dans un bar
ici c'est braver un interdit pour une
femme
oui alors donc là on se rend compte que
c'était sais pas c'est pas du tout ça
voilà c'est que les femmes n'y allez pas
juste voilà c'est tout qu'elle ne se
rendait pas dans ce bar ramous d'abord
après je voudrais dire alors pour
revenir en fait au contenu du livre il
ya des choses moi qui m'ont interpellé
donc moi personnellement étant né dedans
j'ai quand même appris des choses il ya
un passage intéressant vous parlez d'une
d'une gynécologue qui justement est
confronté quotidiennement au fait que
des familles et entre autres sur ce
témoignage là qui était précieux pour
moi vous parler du fait que l a
accueilli une dame avec son mari
pakistanais qui lui a demandé de
recoudre son hymen entre autres une
opération et moi j'ai toujours entendu
cette légende comme une légende urbaine
on a toujours dit oui ça existe et c'est
et je trouve ce témoignage hyper hyper
hyper important puisque ben là vous avez
vraiment la personne qui est confrontée
au quotidien
azor d'intervention et pour moi
personnellement ça m'a choqué et c'est
ce que j'ai retenu de ce livre et j'ai
trouvé ça hyper intéressant de réussir à
trouver un témoignage comme celui-là
c'est vraiment sur tous ces gens là qui
s'expriment à visage découvert ça sont
courageux et dise les choses très
clairement l on parle d'une gynécologue
qui s'appelle ghada à thème qu'il
travaille depuis plus de dix ans
seine-saint-denis qui sait de quoi il
parle et qui observe de plus en plus
justement la montée d'une sorte
d'islamisation qui justement on parle
des réflexions du même il n'y a pas que
ça et donc du coup elle se retrouve à
faire des actes qui la dépasse
complètement
et elle le dit très ouvertement
géraldine maillet et territoires perdus
de la république
la montée du communautarisme moi je suis
un petit peu d'accord avec karim j'ai
l'impression que ça fait 20 ans qu'on
l'entend on l'entend mais de la part de
personnes un peu sulfureuse comme eric
zemmour - l'entente de gilles kepel on
attend d'eux aura habitants que j'adore
sauf que vous là pour la première fois
vous avez la carte vous êtes du côté de
l'as bien
pensant ce médiatique vous êtes comme l
issue du monde est donc enfin on vous
écoute on vous écoute et on dit ah oui
pourquoi pas donc là pour le coup pour
une fois il n'y a pas d'amalgamé ya pas
de stigmatisation il n'y a pas de
discrimination et donc vous êtes audible
- après tout ça me fait me dérange
absolument pas que le 9-3 soit à
dominante musulmane
ça ne pose aucun problème en revanche
effectivement ce communautarisme est ce
qu'il est compatible pour vous et selon
vous avec les lois de la république et
moi je trouve que globalement ce que
vous montrez c'est plutôt non que oui
alors je leur nous on a volontairement
on sait jamais on s'est tenue à la
distance de 2 ce qui relèverait de la
loi ou pas pourquoi parce qu'on n'est
pas procureur on n'est pas policier et
par ailleurs on entre par fouad jaillir
dans des zones grises dans lesquels je
mets au défi quiconque de savoir si
est-ce qu'on peut le faire ou est-ce
qu'on peut pas le faire il ya des cas
qui sont discutables l'employé de la
ratp que notre journal justement je
répète on dit que c'est pas un fait
nouveau il y avait eu des articles
notamment dans l'obs que monsieur me
disait monsieur zeribi portant sur le
dépôt de bus de pavillons sous bois des
pavillons-sous-bois dix ans il ya
beaucoup de rumeurs qui disent que c'est
un repaire d'islamistes c
mais là il n'y a pas de nouveau il ya un
énorme nouveau c'est que c'est la
première fois que la journaliste arrive
à entrer
il a il est entré dans le dépôt de bus
et qu est ce qu ils en concluent
premièrement que c'est pas un repère de
barbus contrairement à ce qu'on a dit
donc il déconstruit la légende et en
même temps il dit pardon pour la formule
qui n'est pas de moi en même temps
qu'est ce qui dit il dit il ya quand
même des comportements qui ce qui pose
problème puisque j'ai vu des personnes
entrées dans une mini salle qui ne sort
deux salles de prière
quand destine alors que normalement à la
ratp comme dans les entreprises
publiques
on n'a pas droit de prier sur le lieu de
travail mais en même temps est ce que
moi je suis vraiment choqué la personne
doit prier et c est ça renvoie un autre
chapitre qui est sûre les patrons de
seine-saint-denis où on met en face à
face en quelque sorte deux patrons de
deux entreprises différentes avec deux
attitudes différence
j'allais dire ultra l'oeil car qui dit
la religion elle s'arrête à la porte de
l'entreprise moi je veux rien voir ici
et un autre qui dit moi je m'autorise à
faire des prières et on ne tranche pas à
la fin parce que je n'ai pas la réponse
et c'est pas moi de la donner c'est au
lecteur de trancher après avoir lu donc
général aoun et c'est une fête
oui oui il faut que j'aille vite parce
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de choses évoquées
vous allez pouvoir me rejoindre après
quelques pages qu'on aura tourné
islamisation c'est pas bon comme terme
on va y arriver après ensuite vous êtes
vous avez fait un travail de journaliste
mais c'est pas bon quoi c'est pas bon on
va y revenir tout de suite oui non
après parce que je peux soit développée
pour y arriver bon d'accord ok j'ai
plein d'idées a fait tourner la tête
[Rires]
c'est pas bon oui et on vous avait
repris des termes qui sont des préceptes
religieux donc ils sont à approfondir et
et puis vous êtes des journalistes donc
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai livre
mais c'est un livre de journalistes et
je vais écrire un chapitre avec vous qui
est celui-là mais l'ont déjà fini le
livre non une réédition en fin de
chapitre
en fait ce qui manque c'est en fait
limitée islamisation c'est pas le terme
parce que moi ma connaissance des
musulmans et de deux de mes frères de
des gens avec qui j'ai grandi et j'ai
traîné
c'est plutôt un rejet du système ça les
dérange le système ils le comprennent
pas et des fois les lois de la
république de notre pays
des fois ils en sont exclus à cause des
deux problèmes sont inaudibles
différent de mon problème et ils sont
inhumés ils veulent du mal à personne
juste y rejette le système est ce qu'ils
lui proposent
oui et donc l'islam lui propose quoi des
trucs spirituelle mais non et on est
également d'accord d'accord les mecs les
jeunes ici ne sont pas contre non bon
niveau des locataires mais on est
d'accord la mise à ce qu'exige sa
fonction c'est pas le terme c'est que
les gens sont heureux selon ce que si
vers le spirituel qui soit d'accord
n'importe quel des français qui nuisent
est la traduction concrète du système
n'a rien à proposer
mais la vraie dans l'explication des
clowns c'est ça la vie ils ont pourtant
je suis d'accord à 0 ni courageux petit
pas on fait ce chapelet temps semble en
fait votre banque
c'est pourquoi les gens vont dans le
spirituel et mais c'est le système il a
plus rien nada cédé la boue tout à fait
vrai que c'est pas les causes enfin
l'écossé ça éclate après car équipe au
monde c'est déjà une bonne soirée
tu mets le doigt sur un truc très vrai
quand tu te détourne des lois du système
de ton pays pour te réfugier dans dans
ta religion c'est une forme de
d'islamisation sais pas si c'est de
façon stable les films les livres la
télé en effet qu'il ya rien de qualité
alors les mecs se disent ah merci pour
les régions non
[Applaudissements]
et
je vous avais prévenu qu'il était en
forme aujourd'hui à il a plus parlé en
une émission quand ces émissions est au
taquet effectivement c'est un fait
effectivement on ne peut pas le nier
et effectivement ce livre est moins pire
dans le fond que dans la forme ce que
c'est vrai qu'on voit inch'allah
l'islamisation en ville à ceux
découverts en quête spotlight spotlight
que vous utilisez en plus de façon
assumée en le comparant au boston globe
et le réseau de pédophilie au sein de
l'église qui a été dénoncée moi je
trouve ça un peu facile un peu un peu
dommage mais le le problème - le seul
problème que j'ai eu avec ce livre c'est
que vous vous défendez de nous relater
que des faits que des anecdotes et quand
ces anecdotes sont prises sans recul
sans mise en perspective
et sans ces données sociologiques et ou
idéologique que vous savez que vous avez
sciemment pris le parti de d'exclure
parfaitement d'unir seulement on tombe
pour moi malheureusement dans
l'islamisation ce que là tu me tues mais
le visage de bernard de la villardière
leur sauta sur la couverture
ça donnait sur enquête exclusive on est
on est on est ce que je considérais que
le contenu du livre c'est pas exactement
ça et ça me paraît et soit là je trouve
ça dommage de le vendre ainsi son ça
dommage de sortir d'une lecture de 21
portrait 21-21 une anecdote est de se
dire bon bah du coup dans le la scène
ces risques décrits dans ce que décrit
le livre parce qu'on l'a déjà connu en
france il ya eu une religion qui est
devenue une idéologie en france et est
l'idéologie catholique qui avait pour
but de contrôler tous les aspects de la
société
on a connu ça et même dans mon enfance
était encore très prégnant on a eu
beaucoup de mal à s'en débarrasser avant
moi ce qui me gêne dans le livre jamais
à faire la paix avec cette religion a
trouvé la laïcité la religion la tolère
la laïcité c'est moi c'est maintenant
laisser le cinéma c'est au tour des
musulmans de faire le même travail et
c'est pour ça que je suis choqué par
certains propos qui sont tenus parce que
notre devoir c'est d'aider les musulmans
modérés dans leur lutte contre la plaque
pieuvre et l'hydre islamique à suivre
islamique s'attaque d'abord aux
musulmans au lieu de chipoter sur tel ou
tel point
on devrait tous les aider voilà qu'on
entend que les signes très vite
carrington non ben alors très vite d'un
rapport accusant va dire long après non
je voulais dire à gérard davet et
fabrice lhomme contrat
ce qu'ils ont imaginé peut-être dans mon
introduction moi c'est pas à charge mais
critique ne les prenais pas ne prenez
pas tout à charge
ce n'est pas sur la défensive on débat
dans un débat ne peut pas d'accord sur
tout j'ai d'ailleurs demandé à la
production même de mettre l'accent sur
un passage du livre
je veux le dire parce que c'est pour
vous montrer je suis pas à charge il
faut le dire vous écrivez le répéter
sans cesse
l'immense majorité des musulmans de ce
pays soient vos souhaite vivre
pacifiquement en respectant les lois de
la république et rejette totalement ces
prédicateurs intégristes et autres
kamikazes sanguinaire dont ils sont par
ailleurs souvent les premières victimes
donc oui mais ça n'empêche pas ça
n'interdit pas le débat pourquoi je suis
un peu gêné
c'est une manière de c'est ma dernière
remarque quand vous confondez ou
juxtaposer ou associés ou additionné aux
utilisateurs que vous voulez des
phénomènes d'islamisation qui me choque
qui nous choque tous sur lesquels on
doit se battre pour faire respecter la
laïcité la république l'additionner ça à
des phénomènes que je qualifie de plus
des phénomènes de société tels à 20,7
euros y'a que des boucheries halal
là on parle de business on n'est pas en
déficit de laïcité ou de république on
répond à une clientèle a besoin de
clientèle pourquoi vous mettez au même
niveau des comportements d'islamisation
qu'il faut combattre avec fermeté sans
pitié avec ya des boucheries halal qui
répondent à un besoin de la population
peut agir à lille qui a mis en seine
saint denis
cette concentration de population qui a
mis en place les questions de finale se
sont assignés à résidence
ils ont tous décidé les musulmans n'a
que sept scènes de nu d'arriver à saint
denis sont allés en vivre ensemble et on
en rejeter les ordinateurs pas comme ça
que ça des gens vont dire mais c'est que
juxtaposés
une innovation
je trouve que quelque part est
intellectuellement ton des jeunes de
qualité saporta cofigeo est au coeur du
livre c'est à dire que je mets au défi
quiconque dans cette salle en lisant
toutes les récits qu'ont fait les faits
que l'on donne de pointe et à chaque
fois ça c'est d'islamisation ça c'est
choquant ça c'est pas choquant quand on
documente le fait à travers des
témoignages c'est même pas nous qui
raconte ont à travers la préfète
déléguée de seine-saint-denis qui
s'appelle fadela benrabia je ne crois
pas qu'elle soit islamophobe et qu'elle
dit prêt à aller dans certains noms mais
c'est important apprécié fadilah berrada
quartier il ya plus de blancs il ya tout
est analysé selon des habitants mais
alors qu'est ce que j'ai à la préfète si
vous voulez c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est elle et est ce qu'elle est ce que
de par sa position
on peut se permettre de donner la parole
je pense que oui je pense qu'elle
connaît mieux la seine saint denis que
moi alors est ce que je dis c'est qu'en
fait l'islam n'est pas dangereux c'est
les gens qui sont dangereux parce que
faut pas non plus faire croire qu'on
n'est pas au courant il ya des endroits
en france donc là on parle de la seine
saint denis il ya des endroits en france
en province où on a l'impression de
rentrer dans un dans un quartier au même
pas loin du centre-ville on a
l'impression de rentrer à alger ou à
tunis où tout est contrôlé où tout est
où tout est millimétré où on a
l'impression de chaque à chaque détour
de ruelle où on a l'impression qu'on est
plus vraiment en france et c'est pas que
c'est un souci mais c'est que je pense
qu'il faut le contrôler et moi
personnellement quand je rentre dans une
rue et j'ai l'impression de me trouver
dans un autre endroit que dans mon
propre pays personnellement moi ça me
gêne donc je trouve que c'est un fait
est qu'il ya des choses quand même dans
steve qui sont qui sont relayés qui sont
pas mal oui certaines choses ont déjà
été dites mais elles sont actualisées au
bout du jourdain le voir si chinois du
xiiie arrondissement c'est exactement la
même chose
absolument donc ça veut dire que
peut-être il ya aussi des politiques
publiques qui nous ont amenés à ces
situationnelle d'accord mais karim il
veut un autre livre
non pas du tout il n'a pas fait enquêter
ils n'ont pas fait enquêter sur les
causes en scène auto moto alors le nom
mais savait ni les causes ni les
conséquences ni l'école ni les
conséquences liées mais tu as raison sur
le fond comment on
il a évidemment là il ya d'autres
quartiers style achètent ou qu'est ce
qu'on fait rythm is it alors il faut
aider il faut aider la majorité qui
conteste sa qui combattent ça fait de
musulmans qui combat tous a déjà rempli
les paniers la réalité c'est chez moi
c'est sciemment et j'en veux énormément
d'enjeux cerveau politique quels gènes
tonnes des hommes politiques selon me
suis jetée secrétaire d'état les gens ou
les oui car j'ai obtenu the politics
moody's et vous avoue à la con moi vous
savez je sais ce que tu as des
transports me parlez pas de 2,1 vraiment
qu'en mai le 4 juillet au conseil des
ministres
ouais il prépare c'est important il faut
l'aimer soleil c'est primordial au lion
béchu mais quand nous étions pour nous
examiner justement parce que
défensivement il donc il a raison quand
y'a rien quand on leur propose rien il
ne faut pas s'étonner et moi c'est pas à
eux que je me tiens non personne ne
prenne ses responsabilités qu'elles
jettent dans les eaux poétique et vidé
mais non mais il n'y a pas de problème
mais on essaie tout le monde fuit ces
personnes précieuse responsabilité par
une sono passion prix ne soyons pas
surpris
alors ya passage très touchant du livre
après jour et non attendre christine
kelly vous rencontrer thierry roy père
de famille encore brisé par le drame de
la mort de leur fils
ce père de famille n'a qu'une crainte
l'installation d'une mosquée en face de
chez lui quand un vrai 23 ans quand il
est mort en syrie après s'être
converties à l'islam et à voir quand
fréquenter la mosquée des radars de
sevran surnommée la mosquée daiichi la
mosquée d'agen
donc c'est une salle de prières
aujourd'hui fermé si tu es donc à sevran
bernard de la villardière avait été du
côté de seront on s'en rappelle on a vu
qu'on n'avait encore vu les images et ce
père de famille redoute une chose
l'installation d'une mosquée en face de
chez eux il s'y tenait des prêches
violents radicaliser dirigé par un imam
extrémiste
en mars dernier une image forte du jus
du jt de tf1 qui avait beaucoup fait
parler
on y voit des élus chanter la
marseillaise face à des religieux
musulmans qui contestaient en faisant
leurs prières regarder en face à face
tendu
le côté des élus de l'autre des
musulmans la marseillaise répondent à
l'appel à la prière
le ras-le-bol d'élus et d'habitants face
à des fidèles qui prient chaque vendredi
dans la rue depuis mars dernier moment
juste que le gouvernement maçon ou le
monde et son boulot c'est interdire les
prières de rue et interdire l'occupation
d'une république c'est normal qu'ils
aient des prêches dans la rue la
manifestation encadrée par la police
municipale a bien failli déraper avant
l'arrivée des gendarmes
selon la déclaration des droits de
l'homme de 1789 les manifestations
religieuses comme les prières de rue
sont possibles à condition qu'elle ne
trouble pas l'ordre public
c'est mon quartier
[Applaudissements]
parfaitement normal c'est que les
musulmans n'est pas de lieux de culte au
pouvoir aller prier décent justement
c'est ça qu'est scandale mayer dans le
livre jeu il n'y a pas une seule
allusion je crois aux prières de rue
parce que pour nous en fait c'est un
faux problème ou en tout cas c'est un
problème pour les musulmans mais c'est
pas un problème d'islamisation ça c'est
un problème de reconnaissance du fait
qu'il ya une communauté qui est
nombreuse et qui a besoin de lieux de
culte le fait de prier dans la rue ils
font pas ça parce que ça leur plaît
d'aller dans la rue il préférait aller à
la mosquée donc en fait ça pour moi
c'est pas ça le sujet par contre le vrai
sujet et c'est bon on l'évoquait juste
avant c'est le fait que des communautés
maintenant vivre entre elle et on
documente fait dans le x alors ça vous
allez me refais déjà été dit mais c'est
pas parce que ça a déjà été dit faut pas
le répéter qu'il ya des membres de la
communauté juive de seine-saint-denis
qui soit quittent la ville le quartier
où il habite pour aller dans une ville
plus sûre où ils se retrouvent entre eux
ou alors il quitte carrément le
département et à linverse évidemment on
va voir les musulmans se regrouper entre
mais où ça va finir ça va finir qu'il y
aura une vie le chi wah d'une ville
maghrébine ou musulmane en l'occurrence
une ville catholique une ville juive
c'est quand même phénomène qui est très
important aussi c'est que certains
profitent de ceux ci pour justement
pratiquer ce qu'on appelle du
clientélisme religieux les as révèle don
libre aussi ça va savoir que s'il ya un
terme qui employait qui est une mosquée
égale trois mandats qui c'est qui a dit
ça au fait tu vois pas ce que vous dites
est interdite il a dit c'est l'élu qui
l'a dit c'est pas un élu c'est mauvais
mais les niches qui dit ça qui dit une
mosquée galles 3 mandats oui c'est un
responsable associatif
absolument l'audi ce temps que
simplement ils sont nombreux à profiter
de ça les musulmans besoin de lieux de
culte les maires ont besoin du vote
musulman bien sûr et donc du coup tout
ceci fait il faut à faire ensemble et ça
devient du clientélisme
c'est un souci aussi que single i wanna
make donc la question alors je dis que
tout est fait pour vous titi un petit
peu c'est que derrière vous deux deux
journées d'investigation j'apprécie
tellement votre travail j'aime tellement
votre côté investigations et quand je
vois livre enquête choc on va vous
donner les preuves et c'est une enquête
un an le terrain et quand on ouvrait
qu'on lit le livre et qu'on voit
effectivement des faits déjà connus
qu'on voit des approximations
quand même mieux eysines minarets
lorsqu'on voit aussi défection et des
faits qui ont été déjà dit des faits qui
ne sont pas vérifiées moi j'ai été un
petit peu déçu voilà ce que je vais y
arriver la société française question à
vous poser est ce que vous êtes allé à
saint denis
il paraît que non pourquoi deuxième
question
pardon c'est leurs élèves qui joue à
l'époque a pas eu des gens avec du lait
sont eux james est votre ami du livre
deuxième question pourquoi est ce que
les noms des cinq journalistes ne sont
pas cool sur la couverture fait pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils sont payés est ce qu'ils
ne sont pas payés et pour moi dernier
mot c'est il pour moi il ne faut pas
confondre stigmatisation et informations
et j'ai l'impression quand même que si
vous vous deux vous auriez été sur le
terrain ça aurait donné un autre
un autre livre et dernière chose bravo
d'avoir eu l'idée d'avoir d'inclure des
journalistes parce que moi aussi j'ai
souvent par les jeunes gens naissent
dans les écoles les amants inclut des
avants envoyés sur le terrain
après je reste quand même un peu déçu il
ya beaucoup de questions de vous être
attrapés oui il ya des questions plus
importantes que doyen alors déjà ou pas
sur la couverture parce que mettre cette
nom sur la couverture c'est impossible
et on a mis les deux noms qui sont qui
parle au public tout simplement d'accord
pour envoyer une bâche dans pioli girard
leur nom et sur la dernière page est à
l'intérieur
et ça leur a pas du tout posé le
problème il reconnaissait que c'était
impossible de les avoir tous
ils n'ont pas été payés c'était à la
demande ils sont ils appartiennent à
l'école de centre de formation du
journalisme qui a demandé à ce qu'ils ne
soient pas payés api pour qu'il n'y ait
pas pour ce soir est un projet
pédagogique et en échange par contre la
segnora de tard ils disent ils ne
peuvent pas avoir de droits d'auteur du
coup donc il va signer avec l'éditeur
c'est vous qui allez signer un contrat
est un contrat justement nous faisons
qu'il n'avait pas droit d'auteur ce
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas après sur les
problèmes principaux est juste je vais
revenir ce que vous lisez au départ je
suis pas d'accord sur le fait qu'à des
faits qui ne sont pas vérifiées tout a
été vérifié et je suis désolé s'il y
avait vraiment de grosses erreurs dans
ce livre ça se saurait les quelques
personnes qui ont contesté nombreux à
contester leurs propos ou contester le
fait qu'elle ne se reconnaissait pas
dans le livre mais ça c'est surtout
parce que les personnes ont peur parce
qu'elles ont parlé et je les comprends
je leur en veux pas voilà pour pour
l'essentiel est que vous ayez quelques
questions oui passage le truc essentiel
c'est qu'on ne prétend pas à la
perfection
non certainement et que toute enquête
est imparfaite par nature voilà mais
celle ci je vous garantis comme dit
fabrice que tous les faits étaient
vérifiés il il peut y avoir des
oxydation éventuellement nuit jean et
minarets oui ça nous a échappé on est on
est faillible
je me contente de vous l'entendre non
mais tout à fait et non mais absolument
rien tout dernier point sur la ce que la
scène me tient à coeur vous fait le
distinguo entre stigmatisation
informations vous avez parfaitement
raison
je pense vraiment qu'on est dans
l'information la stigmatisation c'est
insupportable et je mets en garde en
quelque sorte le l'ensemble des citoyens
des journalistes des débatteurs sur le
fait qu' il n'y a pas de raison qu'on ne
puisse pas trappe parler sereinement de
ce sujet on les bat laon la fin
d'ailleurs et sans que tout de suite ce
soit les stigmatisations je donne
toujours un exemple y en a 200 milles
est-ce que lorsqu'on parle du problème
de la pédophilie dans l'église et
notamment des prêtres est-ce qu'on est à
trôner on est soupçonné d'attaqués la
religion catholique non on parle de
choses qui pose problème de dérive ont
fait la différence
la l'islamisation et l'islamisme en
l'occurrence qui se développe en
banlieue qui est minoritaire on le dit
progresse mais ne représente absolument
pas la majorité des communautés
musulmanes et heureusement alors
qu'harry vous voulez que je voulais
simplement dire est que encore une fois
moi j'ai porté une critique que je veux
constructibles parce qu'il nous faut un
débat voilà a été dit serein mais il
nous faut aussi un débat avec des
arguments et j'ai essayé d'emporter pour
expliquer doctement qu'il fallait être
très scrupuleux très vigilant sur la
dénonciation et le combat qu'ils étaient
menés contre l'islamisation contre
l'islamisme pardon plutôt face à des
phénomènes qui sont plus des phénomènes
de société qui ne sont pas en
contradiction de la laïcité avec ça
c'est pour un bal deuxième point j'ai
envie de vous dire que il ya des défis
pour notre pays et effectivement je
crois que la lutte contre tous les
communautarismes représente un défi
fondamental si on veut vivre nos pas
côte à côte
non pas face à face mais ensemble il va
falloir que nous ayons aujourd'hui des
politiques publiques qui favorise la
mixité
là où ça n'est plus possible on va avoir
un débat sur l'école tout à l'heure vous
avez des écoles reste avec deux
banlieues non mais quand vous avez des
cols de banlieue d'ailleurs le livre
l'indiquent aussi vous avez trame très
jeune au nom et la même origine
maghrébine ou africaine
l'âge une école qui est dite
républicaine et laïque moi ça me pose un
problème de fond
il faut que nous travaillons aujourd'hui
au fait que les français parce que ce
sont des français dont on parle puisse
vivre ensemble mieux se connaître
ne plus se défier ne pas quitter les
quartiers
parce qu'ils se sentent en minorité moi
j'ai grandi dans un quartier quand
j'étais minot ben il y avait des
italiens des espagnols des juifs
les portugais je pense que c'est pas un
doux rêve
je veux pas être mais non c'est hadji de
cette situation je pense qu'elle est
possible à retrouver à condition qu'on
mette en place des mécanismes publics
pour ça que c'est si moi je pense que
c'est fini je pense qu'on a failli
tellement pendant des années des années
qu'on est aujourd'hui dans un système à
l'anglo saxonne avec un communautarisme
avec les quartiers chinois les quartiers
italiens les quartiers hindous comme
comme à londres comme à new york et que
c'est fini la république parce que la
république a abandonné j'ai dit oui mais
son mari le pédalage et un cinéma gauche
x et arrive ça sera notre sujet on va on
va pas les bricoleurs fait d'abord tous
là ça va être ce livre qui permet de
poser les vais jamais je me croyais et
marié ensuite si vous y croyez vous à
quoi un retour en arrière au vivre
ensemble
j'y crois car mais c'est aussi cela je
suis nature persécutoire c'est ma nature
donc ça va cherry inch'allah aux
éditions fayard une enquête spotlight
sur la seine saint denis merci mais avec
des si
[Applaudissements]